This is a fairly simple exercise. You're given a program
that draws two triangles to make a square. Similar to
how this was done earlier. Back-face culling has been turned
on, which has caused one triangle to disappear. Your job is
to determine the problem and fix the triangle's representations so
that both triangles appear. Here's the method you need to fix.
You can ignore the material culls at the top and
the mesh and screen culls at the bottom. The problem has
to do with the geometry culls here in the middle. By the
way, in Three.js Back-face culling is turned in by setting the side
variable in the material. So, here in the Material Creator we set
side to Frontside, which means that only the front faces are visible.